I thought today we could look at garbage
collection which is a form of automatic
memory management so the the problem
here is when you're programming you
never know how much memory your program
will use when it's running so if you're
running an image processing thing you
don't know how big the photo you'll be
editing is if you're a web browser you
don't know how big the web page will be
so you dynamically have to ask that the
operating system give me some memory the
physical part of the Chip And you get
access to it and later you give that
back and you go through this sequence it
turns out to be very difficult to do
that manually and so there are
techniques including garbage collection
that do that automatically so you can't
just say right give me absolutely loads
because I want to be able to use
whatever I want then well you can and
it's like in anything in life you can
ask for all the resources and they might
even be given to you but then no one
else has access to them so you're trying
to balance out being a good citizen uh
with also asking for what you need
typically if you go back to older
programming languages and all you see is
an example if you wanted memory you had
to ask for it and release it yourself so
um there are two Primitives here one's
called malloc and malloc says give me
some quantity of memory please and the
operating system will and I'll simplify
a bit it will then reserve a physical
part of your RAM chip for your program
to use and then free says I'm done with
that block of memory however big it was
you can have it back you can free up
that physical part of the ram chip so if
we have a little look at some actual
code we can see how this works and then
what the challenges are
so here is a very simple C program I
just filled out the skeleton because I
always forget the bits these days
and I can say uh I would like to
allocate uh let's see
32 kilobytes of memory so malloc says
that give me 32 kilobytes of memory
and then I can do things like I can set
so we call that store value so I can say
the first byte I'll just store the
letter H oops
and then I can read values back so I can
say printer character
and then I've got a load
and then when I'm done with that I can
say I would like to free that memory so
that's a very valid little program if
I've got it right let's just quickly
compile it and see how many things I've
got wrong
uh
so it prints out H that's good so that's
things working correctly so I've
mallocked memory and I've read it so
I've been a good citizen I gave the
memory back uh when I was done with it
so several ways this can go wrong the
first one is I forget to free the memory
so there's now what we call a memory
leak if I don't use that bit of memory
for the rest of the program then the the
operating system will think I've still
got claim to it and it won't take it
back even though I may know I will never
need it again and if you have too many
of these memory leaks you run out of
memory the resources are no longer there
so that's something we've probably all
experienced your program just exploding
or if you're machine going into swap
it's often because of this
so that's one mode of getting things
wrong another one is I can free memory
and then try and read and write from it
so when I've moved the free statement
here I'm then reading and writing and
then that program will explode in
various random ways the operating system
will think oh you're done with that
memory I'll give it to someone else or
use it in some other way and you're
trying to read and write from it and
sometimes it works for a while
and then stops working or you get random
data all sorts of problems can happen
and another one which I'm particularly
fond of is where you try freeing the
same memory twice now the operating
system might notice this but what
sometimes happens you say I'm done with
this memory someone else asks for this
memory they get the same pointer like ID
should we say
and then you free it and you free the
memory they're using so they they are
perfectly good citizens of Gotham City
going about their business with no
worries and you've then said they no
longer need the memory and then they go
Splat so these are all I mean there are
some other ones but these are the
classic ways that you can go wrong in
traditional memory management and it
turns out as humans we're incredibly bad
at doing this particularly for big
programs shouldn't the operating system
manage some of this for us is or is that
where we're going with this
sort of so it turns out it's really
difficult for the operating system to do
this but in within our programming
languages we can
um have an automatic memory management
system that then gives things back the
resources back to the operating system
more swiftly without us as humans having
to say malloc and free people have
realized this is a problem for a long
time and in fact perhaps surprisingly
even in the late 1950s the very first
automatic memory management systems were
being created
and the basic idea is that you say I
would like to use some memory and the
automatic memory management system will
work out when you are finished using it
and then it will give it back to the
operating system on your behalf so if
you were to put this in terms of C you
would have malloc but you would no
longer worry about calling free and
because you no longer have to call free
we can get rid of all of these sources
of errors and make things a lot simpler
okay so there's a book it feels like
it's a book coming it feels like it
there is a bot of sorts there's there's
a couple of techniques and one of them
is the obvious one and and has
some trade-offs let's say so the obvious
way of doing this is what's called
reference counting so you say when I
allocate some memory I'm going to put a
little counter saying how many parts of
my program are still using this so when
it's allocated the count will probably
be one and if I give it to someone else
used the count goes up to two and when
they're done using it they put the count
back to one and when the count goes to
zero no one's using the memory it can be
free even go back to things so it's not
fully automatic but it's semi-automatic
and it's definitely less likely to have
problems but there are some consequences
one I've got to remember to add and
decrement these things accurately which
is surprisingly difficult to do
correctly
um the other one is that means every
block of memory now has a little integer
associated with it which takes up extra
memory and surprisingly the literal
adding and incrementing and decrementing
these counts can become surprisingly um
punishing in terms of performance if you
keep handing them out and getting them
back over time
and then just finally reference counting
cannot deal with what are called Cycles
so we'll see a maybe a little example of
that later
um you can end up finding remember me
that you have finished using that where
the counts are always above zero and
cannot be automatically returned so is
that like a memory leak it is it is a
memory leak yes it's absolutely a memory
leak exactly the same consequences your
program just grows but almost worse it
looks to use a program like I finished
using with this memory it looks like
I've done the right thing and yet
somehow it's not being freed
um so that's reference counting has its
place it's still used in in some
languages but what's more commonly used
in most languages now you know your
JavaScript your Javas
um is what's called garbage collection
now sometimes this is used as an
umbrella term but more commonly it's
used to mean a specific type of
automatic memory management where it's
more accurately able to determine when
you have finished using some memory and
it works really really well so maybe we
can see a a little example of that
what I do first of all I just run a very
stupid little small Python program and
we can just see that there must be some
sorted memory management going on
so we'll just make a little class and
we'll make some very long Loop
[Music]
this right so what this program is going
to do is just in a long Loop keep
allocating some memory now naively if
this was C the program the memory usage
would just go up and up over time
because I'm not saying free so when I
say c angle bracket allocate some memory
effectively and we can just force that
to make clear that we're storing some
extra things somebody must be doing
something
and then uh let's run this and we'll run
this in another window as well
so it will
see if I picked a big enough number no I
really need a bigger number to make it
run longer it's going to make it run for
very long so the first one of these
python processes you can see what under
let's take under size uh or actually
under resources which doesn't matter
which one the program keeps running and
it's never using any more memory in this
case it actually turns out using
reference counting at the moment but as
soon as I finish using the memory it's
deallocated that's automatic memory
management of some form working but what
happens if we do something a little bit
more sophisticated so let's kill that
so let's make another new font
and what we're going to do now is just
look
how one of these garbage collection
algorithms work now they turn you can go
into huge depth making these things
super fast but I just I will show you
the basic algorithm which is called a
mark and sweep algorithm where we work
out which memory is still being used
which can be free everything else all
the complexity is just an optimization
to make those stages go faster but they
don't affect the fundamentals so let's
save this one so again I'll just make an
empty class
and what I'm going to do first of all
I'm going to make an object so in Python
this is a blank object what I'm going to
show you is the problem of working at
which memory is live at first so there's
a concept of what are called Roots so
when we allocate memory we have to say
which objects am I still using we call
those the roots and I'll simplify and
say any object reference from a variable
is a root so I'll try drawing and
remembering that I have the artistic
skill of someone with no artistic skills
in fact my artistic skills should be
legendary for their lack of existence so
we'll say I've got a variable X and it's
allocated a chunk of memory over here it
doesn't matter what's in that memory
particularly and I have a reference to
it
so now we can say one of the roots is X
so it's pointing to that memory in the
intuitively that block of memory here is
alive because I'm still pointing at it
and I can make a second variable called
y
and that will also have another block of
memory over here I'm getting some very
variable with arrows here doesn't really
matter intuitively now both of those
boxes of memory are still being pointed
out they have Roots so they're alive
now the first thing I can say is I'm
going to put the null value or none
value in Python's variable y so now I've
effectively removed that pointer there
now so intuitively
this second object the the one with the
thinner lines is no longer being pointed
to so what's going to happen in Mark and
sweep algorithm is the garbage collector
every sort of can say what memory is
still accessible so it's going to start
at the roots and it will say Okay
variable X see what you point to at you
point to something over here so I'll
mark that as tickets being used
variable y That's pointing to nothing
nothing to do there and then it says
right I finished the mark phase of the
algorithm look at all the objects in
memory there are two one of them I
ticked I could reach the other one no
take so I can now deallocate that so
Mark work out what's live sweep get rid
of the stuff that isn't
so that's the very simple version
and then you have to think what happens
if there are more complex graphs than
just two variables and this algorithm is
so simple it scales really nicely
so I will put back the object into why
and I will say that the X object now has
a reference to the Y object
so I have this little line going over
here
okay so now I've got if I was to do run
the mark sweep stage both of those
objects are clearly accessible
but now imagine if again I say why is
none
I get rid of this
and I run the garbage collector first
object I can reach from X yes tick that
and then it will then do what's called a
reachability algorithm effective what
can be reached from this object well if
I go from this object I've just marked
with a tick and via the Y reference oh
yeah look I can take that one as well
it's in use so now I don't want to free
that second one even though it's not
being directly pointed to from a
variable
so in this case it won't have to get rid
of any of those objects in memory and
that in a nutshell is garbage collection
there are some other details perhaps we
want to talk about a few but really
that's the core of the algorithm it's
very nice and simple very intuitive and
the nice thing is it will free all of
the stuff I can't reach so it Suites
where anything that's not marked exactly
so a sweep is just a Boolean flight just
it is this reachable yes or no and if at
the end of this the mark phase it's not
marked as reachable outagos
and this might be completely irrelevant
compared to this but just thinking about
the kind of idea of allocating or
grabbing some memory why don't programs
just get memory when they need it why do
they have to kind of grab some allocate
it and ah okay good question we have
this idea that in in or sometimes we
have this idea that programs such in a
sense like know and Advance what they're
going to need to do
but you know imagine you're writing the
software for like a a web uh like an
e-commerce basket how many items are
people going to put in the basket some
people are going to buy one the
shopaholics are going to buy a hundred
so you never know in advance how much
you'll need to do and so this is really
all about allowing you to dynamically
allocate memory because you just don't
know how much you'll need then I'll be
free so over time your process will its
memory usage will go up and down
depending on what you need and your
process might run for days weeks months
going down to tiny amounts going up to
huge amounts also bearing in mind that
even with a very simple program like the
one I'm writing you can easily allocate
hundreds of megabytes if not gigabytes
per second so if you don't free memory
pretty quickly you won't have resources
really quickly are there any problems
with this then
there is one and it goes back a little
bit to our reference counting example
earlier which is um sometimes people
find they're using say Java which has
amazing quality garbage collection
algorithms and yet their program seems
to leak memory and keep getting bigger
and bigger and bigger
and it's because they've got a route
left in other words they have a pointer
to what looks like one little object and
and which they've forgotten that they're
keeping alive that object points to
directly indirectly to millions of other
objects you know gigabytes of memory and
as long as there's that one little
pointer left the rest of the stuff won't
be freed so occasionally you have this
challenge of my memory is huge and you
have to find often there's this one
little reference you need to clear in
order the garbage collector come with us
all of the other stuff isn't reachable
and there are tools to help you with
that but it's something that all of us
get wrong at some point
and my last question doesn't marking the
memory use memory
yes it does and so I alluded to you
earlier that the real algorithm so say
if you look in the Java virtual machine
that has several different garbage
collectors they go do some amazing
tricks uh to squash down the moments so
the marking thing is one single bit in
memory it's stored alongside some other
information that you have to have around
and so more or less not only does it not
take up any room but implicitly you
remember when I was doing the little
example after each space I went and
cleared the little tick marks the marks
and the proper garbage collectors say
hey even going over all the objects and
and setting them to false the mark bit
that is just too slow so what we'll do
we'll remember last time was it did the
mark bit set to True mean free or does
the market set the false mean free so
they don't have to go around and unset
things
all sorts of little optimizations to
make this as fast as they possibly can
and when you have got a memory leak is
that why we turn things off and on again
yes and I am a a habitual Turner offer
and back on her again because yes it
really does fix memory leaks and many
other patented and unpatented problems
I make that number a lot bigger so I
make it an order of magnitude bigger
this for Loop it now takes a bit longer
and if I make it longer again
we'll see depending on which style of
core it's going on I think it's within
three cycles and then if you go any
longer then it's going to take you
longer you know